when this project was first pitched to
me I said yes quicker than anything I've
ever been presented before that's just
because I have this intense nostalgia I
grew up on Atari the moment that the
first cartridge appeared in the bucket
the first time that I saw a mound of
dirt that had just been pulled out and
there was any T game sitting at the top
of it it was kind of surreal we found
and intact ET the video game ET is
definitely here we are I'm actually
holding a one of the 18 cartridges that
was pulled out of the landfill it was it
was able legend in the video game
industry for three decades and now
finally we can say with absolute
certainty that it is true Atari was
really buried out here in the New Mexico
desert the worst video game ever ET fert
re it was bad brutal unfair didn't make
a lot of sense how did the company that
was so innovative fail so miserably the
zenith of avatar either the point in the
late 70s and early 80s when this kind of
group of sort of creative genius
engineers came together to create this
amazing company and I think it was a
kind of completely unique company at the
time it was doing something that no one
else did over there is where the hot tub
was inside on the first floor there's
some great stuff that went on in that
room over here here's the hill that you
know one day I was wearing a dashiki
shirt which I was very into back then
and I would do somersaults down mayo I
might have had some cocktails that
afternoon
that point did you know that you were
entering this crazy party atmosphere
that you'd be no even though I was told
I was I had no expectation that it could
really exist the best recruiting tool we
could have for an engineer was to bring
him over to one of our parties
they felt hey I'm a nerd her girls here
they're talking to me it's good that was
the coach of these guys are the
lifeblood of the business may go what
they want to do and that's fine that's
what made them the fastest rising
company in American business history and
also made them the fastest following
just the mystery itself was was really
the thing that drew me to it is is that
why after 30 years you so many people
care so much about a bunch of garbage we
needed to find a director who first and
foremost was a part of the gaming
community understood the gaming
community and you know they won a lot of
people who fit that description and it
sort of was a little bit of a no-brainer
he's got a kind of injury fascination
with the evolution of myths and legends
you made a film called incident not
message sort of dealt with mythology and
you know the mythology of Loch Ness I
think the reasons why it's hari buried
these games in the desert they're
actually a little bit more complicated
and mundane than people would like them
to be what we found out was that they
used to crush the games and crushing the
games is more expensive than burying
them so Joe Lewandowski is the guy who
actually figured out where the games
work he's the historian if you will
about four years ago sudden you know a
bunch of people started calling and it's
like one thing come on what's the
interest so it's kind of entertaining to
read all that when you've actually were
there and knowing what had happened and
then we went through the process of
locating and doing all this stuff and
gathering information and witnesses and
it's like maybe there is a story there
was also this guy Jim Heller who
appeared really just weeks before the
movie went into production and Jim was
actually the guy who buried the games he
was the individual at Atari who was
responsible for getting those games and
putting them in this landfill I worked
an Atari from 1976
nineteen eighty-three i do not know
exactly what it was sent up here I just
know it was by the truck once Jim
materialized it really I think it helped
narrow down the search to the point that
we were able to be successful we took up
about 1500 I would say that they thought
were representative of the whole I think
they estimated 750,000 partridges had
been buried but it wasn't just bad games
there were lots of really good games
there the question of what happens to
the cartridges is a little bit
unanswered at least from my point of
view I think they're going to put some
on display I don't know if they're gonna
sell some of them I've heard rumors that
they will there was this funny moment at
the end of shooting where I thought oh
good our cartridges and they were like
no not your cartridges you're just
making a documentary oh yeah right yeah
I'm gonna give you one of the games that
we pulled from the ground are you
serious I am and I should tell you this
is illegal because technically the city
owns it so you could go to jail put it
in your pants before you walk out
hello there I'm Howard Scott Warshaw
designer of yars revenge raiders of the
lost ark and ET subscribe to the wired
channel for more action like